to some health news now here at noon the  cdc is recommending that people get a  coveted booster shot eight months after  you get your second shot for many that  falls right around the time for flu  shots initially people were advised  against getting other vaccines so close  together but now doctors say they  recommend getting a covey booster and a  flu shot around the same time and if  you're on the fence about that flu shot  doctors don't recommend skipping it as  this winter flu cases will likely come  back in full force we were working from  home or doing school from home we were  limiting the number of contacts that we  had and we were all masking now  obviously that has changed and will  probably remain changed going into this  winter  researchers are already discussing a  combo shot that would cover both the  coronavirus and the flu but doctors say  it's too early to say when that could be  developed